สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะก็กลับมาเจอกับเราสองคนในวีดีโอระดับอะไรคะในวีดีโอระดับ
beginner  Class
ค่ะใช่แล้วนะคะก็เจอกับครูหญิงแล้วก็ครูฟ้านะคะเหมือนเดิมถ้าจะเหมือนเดิมก็คือวันนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
วันอาทิตย์ที่เท่าไหร่คะครูฟ้าวันอาทิตย์ที่วันอาทิตย์ที่
6 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมีนาคมปีพ.ศ.อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้าเมื่อวานนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 5
เดือนเดือนมีนาคมปีพ.ศปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศปีค.ศ
20225 พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันจันทร์วันจันทร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันจันทร์ที่
ค่ะเดือนมีนาคมปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศ
ค่ะเวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลาบ่าย
4 โมง 4 โมงเย็น
4 โมงเย็น
16:00 น
กี่นาทีคะ
31 นาทีค่ะ
นาทีเนาะตอนนี้ก็เป็นเวลากลางวันแล้วก็เป็นตอนเย็นสมัยเป็นตอนเย็นแล้วนะคะ
[เพลง]
วีดีโอนี้เราก็จะหมด
31 ใช่ไหมแล้วเราก็บวก 20
ใช่ไหมคะก็เป็น 5  4 โมง 51
นาทีค่ะครูฟ้า
นาทีใช่ไหมคะตอนนี้ก็เป็นเวลาเย็นแล้วเนาะผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะก็ตื่นนอนกันตั้งแต่แบบอย่างผู้หญิงวันนี้ผู้หญิงก็ตื่น
8:00 น
โด้ 8:00 น
ฟ้าตื่นกี่โมงคะวันนี้ครูฟ้าตื่น 6
โมงเช้าค่ะ
เอามากครูฟ้าตื่น 6:00 นครูหญิงตื่น 8
[เพลง]
โมงเช้าใช่ไหมอาบน้ำแล้วก็ใส่เสื้อตัวนี้มาตั้งแต่
8:00 น
จนถึงตอนนี้ใช่ไหม 4 โมง
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตั้งแต่ 6 โมงจนถึง 4
โมงผู้หญิงเนี่ยอีก 8 โมงใช่ไหม
9:11:00 นเที่ยง 13:00 น 14:00 น 15:00
น 16:00 น
ผู้หญิงใส่เสื้อบ่ 8
ชั่วโมงแล้วค่ะครูฟ้าถ้ายังไงครูฟ้าก็คง
ชั่วโมงใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าก็ 10 ชั่วโมง
เหม็นแล้วค่ะ
[เพลง]
เหม็นแล้วหรอแล้วต้องทำยังไงอ่ะผู้หญิงเหม็นแล้วอ่ะต้องไปซักแล้วค่ะครูฟ้าต้องซักเสื้อแล้วค่ะซักผ้าซักผ้าแค่
หรอผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่ซักผ้าทุกวันใช่ไหมคะวันจันทร์วันอังคารวันพุธวันพฤหัสบดีวันศุกร์วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์ทุกวันซักผ้าไม่ค่ะเหนื่อยเหนื่อยใจครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะ
เดือนแล้วกันเนาะผู้หญิงเนี่ย 1
อาทิตย์ซักผ้า 1 ครั้งก็คือ 1 ครั้ง
ใช่ไหมคะ
อาทิตย์ซักผ้า 1
ครั้งครูฟ้าล่ะคะครูฟ้าซักผ้ายังไง 1
อาทิตย์
1 อาทิตย์ 1 ครั้งหรือว่า
1 เดือน 1 ครั้งหรือว่า
1 ปี 1
ครั้งคุณครูฟ้าหรือว่าซักทุกวันค่ะเหมือนครูหญิงวันอังคารวันพุธวันพฤหัสบดีวันศุกร์วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์
7 วันก็ซัก 1 ครั้งใช่ไหมคะ
1 อาทิตย์ 1
ครั้งครูฟ้าชอบซักผ้าเนี่ยตอนกลางวัน
หรือว่าตอนกลางคืนผู้สาวชอบซักผ้ากลางวันหรือว่ากลางคืน
คือปกติเวลาครูพาไปออฟฟิศใช่ไหม
แล้วพวกเราก็ไปออฟฟิศทำงานทำงานทำงาน
เลิกงานทำงานเสร็จแล้วก็กลับมาอพาร์ทเม้นท์
ประมาณ
18:00 น
จะถึงอพาร์ทเม้นท์เนี่ย
18:00 นใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็ซักผ้าครูฟ้าชอบซักผ้าตอนกลางคืนค่ะเพราะว่า
โมงเย็นเนี่ยเป็นตอนเย็นใช่ไหมมันก็จะเปลี่ยนเป็นเวลากลางคืนไม่ชอบซักผ้าวันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์
งั้นครูฟ้าซักผ้าวันอะไรอ่ะ
วันพุธค่ะนักเรียนวันพุธค่ะเพราะวันเสาร์อาทิตย์เนี่ยมันฮอลิเดย์เราก็ต้องเบรกใช่ไหมไม่ทำงานแล้วก็อีกอย่างนึงก็คือวันเสาร์
วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์เนี่ยทุกคนทุกคนทุกคนเนี่ยคิดซักผ้า
เพราะฉะนั้นไม่งั้นก็จะคนซักผ้าเยอะใช่ไหมคนๆๆซักผ้า
อพาร์ทเม้นท์อ๋องั้นก็แปลว่าเวลาที่ครูฟ้าซักผ้าเนี่ยครูฟ้าไม่ได้ซักไม่ได้ซักเองไม่ใช่มีมือแล้วก็ผ้าฟักๆๆใช่ไหมครูฟ้าใช้เครื่องซักผ้าใช่ค่ะคุณฟ้าใช้เครื่องซักผ้าค่ะเครื่องซักผ้าให้ดูดีไหมนะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
นักเรียนกดออกแล้วนะคะได้ค่ะกูว่าแชร์สกรีนก่อนนะคะผู้หญิงอนุญาตแล้วใช่ไหมคะโอเคเครื่องซักผ้าแบบฝาหน้าเปิดฝาหน้าตรงวงกลมฝาหน้าอันนี้เครื่องซักผ้าแบบฝาบนขึ้นอพาร์ทเม้นท์ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเครื่องซักผ้าเป็นแบบไหนคะฝาหน้าหรือว่าฝาบน
[เพลง]
ที่อพาร์ทเม้นท์ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเครื่องซักผ้าเป็นแบบฝาบนค่ะแบบนี้แบบนี้เครื่องซักผ้าที่อพาร์ทเม้นท์เนี่ยไม่ใช่ของครูฟ้าใช่ไหมของอพาร์ทเม้นท์ใช่ของอพาร์ทเม้นท์ครูฟ้าต้องจ่ายเงินกี่บาทอ่ะเวลาซักผ้าที่อพาร์ทเม้นท์
1 ครั้งเนาะ
20 บาท
บาทของครูหญิงอ่ะครูฟ้าเครื่องซักผ้าเล็กๆ
บาทนะของผู้หญิงเนี่ย 30 ถึง 50
บาทแล้วแต่ไซส์เล็กๆก็ 30 บาท 40
บาทใหญ่ๆก็ 50
บาทแพงอ่ะแล้วเวลาครูฟ้าซักผ้าใช่ไหมซักผ้าด้วยเครื่องซักผ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยใช้
ใช้แบบไหนอ่ะผู้หญิงมีช้อยส์ให้เลือกนะแบบที่
ก็คือเราเรียกว่าผงซักฟอกอันนี้มันจะมันจะเป็นผงนักเรียนมองเห็นไหมคะผงซักฟอกมันก็จะเป็นผงผงใช้น้ำยาซักผ้าอันนี้เป็นน้ำยาเป็นน้ำเนาะเทออกมาเป็นน้ำนะคะเป็นน้ำใช้อะไรอ่ะใช้ผงซักฟอกหรือว่าใช้น้ำยาซักผ้าคะครูฟ้าใช้อันนี้ค่ะ
ฟ้ามีช้อยส์ที่ 3 ค่ะคุณหญิง
หรอคะ
ไม่ได้ใช้ผงซักฟอกแล้วก็ไม่ใช้น้ำยาซักผ้า
[เพลง]
ใช้อะไรซักผ้าอันนี้ค่ะอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะครูฟ้าเออเรียกเจลแมคเจลบอลน่ะมันเป็นรูปกลมอ๋อมันจะเป็นแบบนี้แล้วก็ใส่ลงไปหรอคะไม่ต้องฉีกไม่ต้องค่ะใส่ลงไปเลยอันนี้ก็ดีเนาะยาซักผ้าใช่ไหมคะขวดไหมได้ๆๆค่ะขวดน้ำยาซักผ้าขวดรีฟิวใช่ไหมอันนี้
refill
เนี่ยมันจะราคาถูกแต่เราเนี่ยต้องมาตัดใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็เทใช่ไหมเทสะอาด
Essence อันนี้ก็ได้
เทใส่เครื่องซักผ้าเป็นเจลบอลก็ดีนะหยิบแล้วก็ใช่ไม่ต้องคิดใส่จะใส่เท่าไหร่ใส่นิดหน่อยใส่เยอะๆใช่ไหมไม่ต้องคิดง่ายๆไงเจอบอลก็ใส่เลยนะคะแล้วเจลบอลของครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีกลิ่นไหมมีค่ะอย่างอันนี้ใช่ไหมอย่างผงซักฟอกอันนี้เนี่ยอันนี้เป็นกลิ่นกุหลาบเห็นไหมคะเป็นกลิ่นดอกกุหลาบกลิ่นน้ำหอม
[เพลง]
ของครูหญิงก็เป็นกลิ่นเหมือนกันนะคะและกลิ่น
floral นะคะอันนี้เนาะน้ำยาซักผ้า
กลิ่นน้ำหอมค่ะดาวนี่เป็นแบรนด์ดาวนี่ใช่เพราะว่าของครูหญิงเนี่ยเป็นยี่ห้อ
essence
[เพลง]
นะคะเอสเซ้นส์ของครูฟ้าเนี่ยดาวนี่บราวนี่หอมมากแล้วเรื่องซักผ้าใช่ไหมเครื่องซักผ้าที่คอนโดอพาร์ทเม้นท์ครูฟ้าเนี่ยมันเครื่องซักผ้าเนี่ยนะคะเวลาครูฟ้าซัก
1 ครั้งใช้เวลากี่นาที
60 นาที
นาทีเร็วมาก
นาทีไม่ได้อ่ะแล้วเวลาที่ครูฟ้าซักผ้าใช่ไหมมันก็จะมีเสื้อเนาะอันนี้คือเสื้อใช่ไหมแล้วมันก็จะมีแบบกางเกงเลยอ่ะ
[เพลง]
น้องฟ้าต้องพูดครูหญิงรู้ก็คือครูฟ้าไม่แย่ค่ะเสื้อสีขาวเสื้อสีน้ำเงินซักด้วยกันเสื้อสีขาวเปลี่ยนสีน้ำเงินเวลาเราใส่สีขาวทุกวันมันก็เบื่อไงเราก็เลยเอาเสื้อไปเปลี่ยนเป็นสีน้ำเงินน้อแฟชั่น
ครูฟ้าไม่แยกไม่แยกไม่แยกเสื้อขาวเนาะเราเรียกว่าเสื้อขาวหรือว่าผ้าขาวภาษีไม่แยกซักรวมกันผู้หญิงก็ไม่แย่ค่ะ
มันก็โอเคนะแต่ถ้าสมมุติครูฟ้าซื้อเสื้อใช่ไหมสีน้ำเงินเป็นแบบน้ำเงินวันนี้ไปช้อปปิ้งแล้วก็ซื้อเสื้อมาอันนี้แยกค่ะอ๋อถ้าเสื้อนี้เนี่ยซักครั้งแรกแย่แย่เพราะว่าถ้าไม่แยกเนาะเสื้อสีขาวเสื้อสีน้ำเงินเนี่ยซักด้วยกันแล้วเสื้อสีขาวเปลี่ยนสีน้ำเงินสีตกใช่ไหมสีน้ำเงินเนี่ยมันก็จะตกใส่สีขาวสีตกแล้วครูฟ้าแยกเสื้อผ้าใช่ไหมเสื้อกางเกงชุดเดรสแล้วก็แบบ
[เพลง]
กระโปรงเนี่ยนะเขาเรียกเสื้อผ้าใช่ไหมเสื้อกางเกงกระโปรงกับเสื้อผ้าถุงเท้ากับถุงเท้าครูฟ้าแยกไหม
ครูฟ้าไม่ใส่ถุงเท้าหรอ
แต่ครูฟ้ามีรองเท้าผ้าใบไม่ใช่หรอทำไมจำไม่ได้ว่าเคยซักคู่ฟ้ามีรองเท้าผ้าใบอันนี้ต้องเปิดให้นักเรียนดูใช่ไหมคะ
ครูฟ้าเปิดใช่ไหม
เนี่ยรองเท้าผ้าใบต้องมีถุงเท้าครูฟ้าต้องมีถุงเท้าสิคะ
ไม่ได้สิถุงเท้าเนี่ยต้องซักค่ะซักถุงเท้าทำไมไม่มีการใส่ถุงเท้าอยู่ในหัวเป็นมานานแล้วหรออ๋อหรืออาจจะอย่างนี้ก็ได้นะอย่างคอนโดมิเนียมครูหญิงใช่ไหมคะมีเครื่องซักผ้าใช่ไหมเครื่องซักผ้าที่คอนโดมิเนียมครูหญิงเนี่ยเครื่องซักผ้าเนาะนักเรียนเครื่องซักผ้าคอนโดมิเนียมกูอีกเนี่ยซักเสื้อโอเคซักกางเกงโอเคซักชุดเดรสใช่ไหมชุดเดรสโอเคกระโปรง
กระโปรงโอเคแต่ถุงเท้าเนี่ยอืมไม่ได้ข้ามแต่ปกติเวลาซักถุงเท้าจะมีกะละมังซักมือไงใช้มือซักไงมีกะละมังซักผ้ากะละมังใช่ไหมเราก็ใส่น้ำลงไปแล้วก็ถุงเท้าใส่แล้วก็ใส่แล้วก็ซักแล้วครูฟ้าซักถุงเท้าเองเนี่ยใช้แปรงไหมคะไม่ค่ะใช้มือ
ใช้มือขยี้ขยี้ขยี้ขยี้ได้เลย
คุณแม่ให้ใช้มือใช่เพราะว่าเวลาที่เราซักผ้าเองใช่ไหมอย่างคนไทยเนาะบางครั้งอ่ะถุงเท้านะคะแล้วก็พวกชุดชั้นใน
ชุดชั้นในค่ะนักเรียนชุดชั้นในอ่ะผู้หญิง
ชุดชั้นในอย่างนี้อ่ะคนไทยเนี่ยซักเองใช่ไหมไม่ใช้ไม่ใช้เครื่องซักผ้าเครื่องซักผ้า
บอกอ่ะมีกะละมังมีกะละมังแล้วก็มีแฟ๊บใส่แซ่บตีๆๆๆๆๆๆๆแล้วก็อาจจะใช้มือขยี้หรือว่าใช้แปรงขัดๆๆๆๆๆคนไทยบางคนเนี่ยแยกนะคะแยกเสื้อกับกางเกงสมัยกางเกงอ่ะแยกกันเสื้อกับถุงเท้าแยกกันนะคะไม่ซักพร้อมกันนะบางคนซีเรียสเนาะแบบไทยนะแบบไทยแต่ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าไม่ซีเรียสนะคะผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยซักพร้อมกันนักเรียนซักผ้ายังไงแยกไหมก็
comment บอกเขาได้นะคะ
วันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะแล้วเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะ